[Music]
the image if you're watching on nbcsn of
bobby orr soaring through the air
superman style
you've seen it before and when you think
of hockey that's got to be one of the
first pictures you think of and if
you're listening on the radio see i was
concerned about doing a segment based
upon iconic nfl images but here's the
thing if you hear it you instantly know
what we're talking about bobby orr you
know it's bobby orr superman style
caught in midair that is the photo that
you think of when you think of hawk and
it's relevant because the bruins and the
blues back together again in the stanley
cup final 49 years after the fact right
like i don't know if there's really any
image in the history of the nfl that can
truly just compete with it like to the
extent you just said where it's just you
say a name and people think of that
exact moment that's to me where it's
going to be very interesting i feel like
other sports have a few more of those
moments the nfl has more of a
long history of those moments it's hard
to pick which one
well and that leads us to today's draft
we are going to select the most iconic
nfl images and really the ultimate
litmus test is for the people listening
on radio or via podcast if they know
right away
what we're talking about that's right
it's a good iconic image so
uh the iconic image that we do every day
the rigged coin toss you're probably
going to call i have a feeling you're
going to call tails you're trying to and
look i assume there's a psychology to it
she just hits the button after she hears
what you've called i know how this works
go ahead well no i'm picking heads she
feels bad for you because you got lots
of eggs smashed on your head so go ahead
heads
heads it is today
she went with tails and then damn so she
really didn't like you darn it
all right and for me there are so many
to choose from and i've gone back and
forth on
what the most enduring image is um
and uh you know what i've got to start
with chuck bed and eric
because
the one thing that sears into the brain
okay the is that this picture of bed
narrative like this that's right with
his with his with his hand down elbow
out over frank gifford a hit that he
applied to frank gifford that knocked
him out of football for over a year that
image of chuck bed and eric now look the
game has evolved
dramatically in the years since then but
bednarik standing over the fallen frank
gifford something that uh you know when
you think of football especially old
school football it's chuck bed and eric
over frank gifford yeah that's a mike
that's a great one it really is i mean
just as a still framed shot just like
that
you know that's up there with maybe any
picture in the history of the sport it
really is i mean and of course frank
gifford was such a star at the time and
it's giants eagles so
i hear you that's a good pick by you all
the way okay
i'm going into the 70s i'm going
steelers i'm going to immaculate
reception i'm going to that image of
franco harris
going down to the ground to pick up the
ball i believe there's a statue outside
of the pittsburgh steelers stadium as
well uh on this exact play the
immaculate reception yeah did the ball
bounce off a steal or did it bounce off
a raider i don't know if it bounced off
a steel or it should have been a legal
catch we can't see if the ball was
actually touching the ground there's a
lot of that either way we know this was
the start at the very start of the
pittsburgh steelers dynasty in the 70s
so to me that is one i look at and if
anybody's watching on tv right now we're
showing the highlight that i just will
always be you know branded in my brain
at least not only just the highlight
itself but when we see that end zone
picture right of just square face on
franco harris coming at us kind of
timing here it is bam that to me is one
of the most iconic images in the history
of the nfl
yeah yeah but but chris it's really not
a photo is it i mean i you know i don't
want to quibble here uh they found a
still frame but that's not the one
you're talking about there is no still
frame of the moment that is captured by
the statue at the pittsburgh airport
when frank o'hara's caught the ball
there's no photo of it and and uh that's
one of the reasons why one of the
enduring controversies is whether or not
the ball actually touched the ground at
or about the time harris was catching it
so i don't know that i would i would put
that up there with one of the top plays
of all time but from the standpoint of a
still frame there really is no still
frame of franco harris making that catch
so i got to throw the challenge flag
there's another one of him going down to
get it i've seen the image before but i
don't really i didn't go just office you
know if you want an image of it freeze
the screen on the video there's your
picture okay take a picture of that
that's right damn it that's all right
we're going iconic images you know it's
a moving sport all right
all right um
there there are so many others to choose
from and because
of the one that you picked i am going to
jump on this one because there is a
still frame of it it was on the cover of
sports illustrated it was the moment
that dwight clark launched the 49ers
dynasty with the catch leaping above
everson walls catching the ball in the
back of the end zone that for me and
that that was that was the
um if you grew up in the 70s and 80s
that was the sea change moment in the
nfl where it stopped being about the
steelers the cowboys the dolphins and
the raiders that's when one of the teams
that had stunk for all those years
finally said hey you know what dallas
cowboys sit your ass down there's a new
team that is going to win championships
there's a new team that is going to be
relevant that was a moment and uh you
know but i hope we have the still there
it is there it is
and uh that is powerful and that is uh
from the days of color photography for
me one of the best images in nfl history
yeah well it's uh again it's you know
the birth of a dynasty and the kind of
the death of another dynasty as far as
the cowboys were concerned you know
they're running the 70s and you know of
course they go through a little bit of a
dry spell in the 80s and the 49ers are
are the team or one of the reasons uh
that they go through that dry spell you
know hey sprint right option
that's the play they ran there down in
the end zone and that's a famous play in
the west coast offense or anybody that
you know really pays attention to nfl
football uh really special and of course
there's like controversy around the play
too did joe montana know he was going to
be there was he throwing the ball away
no he wasn't throwing away he knew he
was going to be there and it was a great
catch by the the late great uh dwight
clark okay man i don't know where you
don't have to take a picture of your tv
to see the still frame to see the photo
of dwight clark making things yep that's
all right mine are better
this early this was good video why would
you want to see a still frame when you
could see the damn video okay so here we
go the whole point of this exercise
inspired by the bobby orr still frame is
to identify enduring still frame images
not enduring video images but please
continue
regardless it's iconic images that had
nothing to do with a photograph it said
iconic images
nothing in the language of any lawyer
that i talked to in the northeast said
it had to do with images just said
iconic images that's all it said so
i didn't talk to any lawyers okay go
ahead here we go
here we go okay my next one um i'm not
sure wait which one did i want okay i'm
gonna go with another video i'm going
with a commercial mike i'm going with a
commercial i'm going with mean joe green
throwing the jersey at the kid in the
coke commercial okay that's an iconic
image and there was a still shot because
there was an ad in in magazines at the
time as well for coca-cola you're trying
i got to give you credit you're trying
to still shot so it's both but okay that
to me when mean joe green you know at
that time of course defensive lineman
you're not being you know publicized in
commercials and the kid coking a smile
and joe green throws the jersey at the
kid and says hey kid and throws it to
him lets him keep it come on that's one
of the greatest commercials in the
history of professional sports that's an
iconic image mean joe green being nice
to a little kid
i'm putting it on my list yep that would
be an excellent pick if this draft were
the best commercials of all time
related to the nfl this is not what it's
about i don't man i'll tell you what you
you the three-day weekend uh did not go
down well
that was iconic friday i started
rattling them off i could go six rounds
on these i was worried that you were
gonna take some of my best ones and uh
you know i still have my full my full
arsenal i don't know who to choose in in
the third round you didn't you haven't
touched any of the ones that i had ready
to go right here's where i'm going
here's where i'm going and this is a
tough one for me but i want to stay on
the football field there's one i want to
go off the football field for it but i i
think that this one um and this i i this
was almost my first pick but i had a
feeling that you would not pick this one
the image of why a tittle
on his knees
bloodied beaten and broken and i still
don't know what the circumstances
surrounding that moment were right but
there is nothing that speaks to
the pain
there is nothing that speaks to look at
that the the misery that you know the
agony of football defeat then that image
of why a tittle and it was taken before
i was born and again to this day i still
don't know what led to that but there's
just something about that that is
haunting to me and it's always been for
50 years that i've been following
football that that is a a haunting
iconic unforgettable image it's a great
picture yeah i get it it can't be that
iconic though if we don't know what the
hell it's about okay so you know you
don't have to know what it's about but
it's still iconic it tells us football's
tough and why a went through a tough day
there we know that that's all i know but
i'm not going to say it deserves on this
list i don't know why but i'm just
trying to argue for argument's sake okay
that's why
i don't like it i don't you don't even
know why do you not look it up how do
you not look it up when you know you're
going to need to i don't need i don't
need to know i mean if i see a ghost i
don't need to know the story of the
ghost all i know is it's a ghost and to
me that is the closest thing there's
just something about that that has
always been what if i told you this was
that was a pre-season game in the 1957
season they played 20 they played 20
pre-season games then who cares i don't
it wasn't i don't really know that i
just wanted to say that all right okay
go ahead go ahead tell me tell me what
other commercial video whatever it is
other than a still frame that you've
decided you're definitely getting a
video here it's just whether it's i
don't know whether to go with john elway
in the helicopter mode in the super bowl
against the green bay packers or do i go
with bill belichick running off the
sidelines right so i'm gonna go with
elway here okay uh elway green bay
packers john elway
never had won a super bowl he was 0-3
this is one of the most iconic images in
the history of the nfl for me right here
the 38 year old quarterback doing
anything he can to try to win a super
bowl against you know the great green
bay packers who had won a super bowl and
brett favre is the nfl mvp so wait still
shot it right there so it becomes iconic
bam look at that it's a picture
whoa yes
somebody still shot it
not nearly as compelling like that not
nearly as compelling but no joke when i
think about the history of the nfl and
just like the montage of things that
come into my brain i really do think of
that video of john elway scrambling out
to his right and his face with his teeth
kind of showing and like oh my gosh i'm
gonna have to jump here and get crushed
who cares i gotta win a super bowl to me
that was one of the the greater images
in the history of the sport
all right we got to take a break i i in
the next segment there are some others
that didn't make the list that i want to
share with you because you picked three
that i never would have picked if i had
picked 20 i wouldn't have even gotten
close to the three you picked i've got
chuck bed and eric over frank gifford
dwight clark making the catch why a
tittle kneeling bloody in the end zone
you have franco harris immaculate
reception the mean joe green commercial
whatever that means and the john elway
helicopter run we drafted the most
iconic images in nfl history last
segment
and i have some others chris that
actually are images they're not videos
they're not commercials they're not
still frames that somebody took off of a
tv set these are iconic images as well
that that uh you're old you went with
black and white pictures i went with
videos on the new age
let's let's start with one and and this
meshes with uh the news from over the
weekend the passing of bart starr
star scoring that touchdown going into
the end zone in the ice ball play that
he suggested on the sideline to vince
lombardi he said the footing is is too
treacherous for the running backs so uh
i i just want to take the ball in myself
lombardi said all right let's run it and
get the hell out of here and they did
and they won and there's bart starr
bottom of the pile across the goal line
in the ice bowl to win the game for the
packers and when i think of lombardi the
photo of lombardi on the shoulders of
jerry cramer yeah with kramer beaming up
at vince lombardi how is that one of
those one of the most memorable it's
clearly one of the most memorable images
in nfl history it's look at that it's
just
joy and happiness respect and love and
everything that that football is all
about
other than having someone that's pretty
cool
although that's part of it too i guess
here's one more that that i thought
about that i thought this is one that
that speaks to the modern era of
football
super bowl three nothing from the game
yeah the beast
when he made the guarantee well you
could have had it man
instead of going with commercials joe
namath talking to reporters poolside
when he made the guarantee that the jets
were going to beat the heavily favored
baltimore colts from 50 years ago that
to me
again it's the only one that strays away
from the field but it was so powerful
because he did something that was
regarded as audacious at the time
and he delivered on it and and
guarantees have become trivialized in
the 50 years since then at the time you
never breathed a word like that
guaranteeing a victory especially under
circumstances like that and to pull it
off amazing and the the moment where you
just blurted it out there nothing like
it hanging out poolside in miami yeah no
that is one that i would look at and go
yeah i should have i should have uh i
should have picked that one that was a
famous famous image certainly
and yeah i i forgot about that one
completely because i just my mind went
to all football stuff honestly i don't
even know if there's an image of this
but one of the greatest nfl images to me
is tom landry on the sidelines with his
little hat on right i mean to me that
always burns in my brain i know there's
an image out there somewhere you know i
grew up watching nfl films that's you
know still black and white photos but
yeah i mean to me that's one of the
iconic images in the history of the nfl
one of the all-time greats with this hat
on on the sidelines i mean that is
always cool there's the david tyree
catch you know from eli manning at super
bowl 42 with the patriots kidding i
don't know if i had that one too i don't
know if i've ever seen a picture of it
though i've only seen a video i've never
seen a picture no there's people there's
there's plenty of pictures there's also
a picture hey hang on a second there's
also iconic images from college football
and uh paul pabst our our friend from
the dan patrick show executive producer
there sent this along during our last
segment iconic image from college
football that you may be familiar with
although your back was turned at the
time
how you like that one sims that's great
thank you this is an nfl show though
let's try to stay on on task okay
thank you paul appreciate your help
uh yes that stunk there chris sims
getting plowed by roy williams hey but
at least you got the ball out no i did
throwing it i didn't get it he hit it
before but you know yeah texas fans are
so mad at me there i was supposed to
block throw and catch that one all at
the same time
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports